[Musique]
thierry bizot le loup était mou c'est
vrai parce que dans tous les programmes
y avait marqué direction des
divertissements qui rit 18 mois mais ses
idoles d'en passer par tous de suicide
le beh moi je suis jamais rentré le bac
le bac et thierry bizot non avec 19 chez
amath sall est plus courte l'histoire je
suis arrivé il y avait des grilles on
faisait la queue 194 en a fait un lieu
de 45 minutes une heure il fallait
tourner sur la droite pour entrer une
grosse porte en bois et avait deux
vigiles en face on arrive avec mon pote
tony est venu vous venez faire quoi je
m'en viens danser mais vous n'êtes pas
compagnie czm lme façon de nancy tu me
l'ait jamais rentrée comment tu veux
dire allez-y monsieur bonne soirée
il enlève la grille pour qu'on continue
la rue pierre charron tout droit
jusqu'au dessus mais en fait il en fait
il ya les hiboux bonne soirée la rue est
à vous et nous a déjà regardé comme ça
ça a pas l'air de vous on va s'occuper
de ce vol mais j'ai un petit apéritif
pour violer l'histoire du bâtiment
alors elle se tournera compter une
deuxième cohorte un petit apéritif
aurait parlé de vous cyril parce que ce
week-end vous étiez invité surprise
jean-pierre foucault sur rtl dans on
refait la télé jean-pierre que j'aime
c'est vrai mais nous aussi on aime
beaucoup
tout le monde a repris vos propos dans
les médias moi je m'en fous de ce que
vous avez raconté ce qui m'a intéressé
c'est une chose particulière
regardez-moi ça
[Musique]
dont jean pierre foucault était très
content de vous voir et malgré votre
doudoune tellement grande que pour y
ranger 23 passe partout eric dussart
vous demander si vous aviez bientôt
devenir notre présent la république qui
commente une éventuelle candidature à
une à 11,10 qui n'est pas en train de se
prendre au jeu finalement si leur état
n'a pas du tout c'est sûr que nous on
paie 0 % de chance moi je vous dis alors
comme tout le monde j'ai été happé par
les interviews mais surtout happé par
cette fameuse doudoune et en fait j'ai
trouvé à quel personnage très célèbres
ou me faisait penser
[Musique]
jeudi je suis fou de cette double honte
à new york la vienne où il entraînait
aussi mais c'est ça bellerive bah oui
c'est pas placement de produits sains
non pas du tout aurait été jeté au cap
là sont pas là c'est jerry alors je me
trouvais et jerry kelly nobes elle
tellement habituée alors samedi soir
j'avais le choix entre faire un monopoly
chez valérie benaïm ou regarder the
voice ouais j'ai bien sûr préféré
regarder the voice alors je veux ce qui
malheureusement n'a pas trop fonctionné
alors regarder les audiences je suis
dégoûté à jamais une émission mais j'ai
un conseil à donner à 2 volts ne
donnerait juste après juste après j aime
l'émission je veux que ça décolle
c'est vrai parce que là c'est bon on a
lacombre rsa sabre de sang mais je
comprends pas pourquoi ça marche pas je
kiffe ou qui fait pas de bruit
téléspectateurs et jusqu'au jour de vote
chaque semaine et chaque semaine en plus
des spectateurs ils me disent non chaque
semaine dix minutes en équipe à je vous
recommande reçoit est ce que vous dites
est vrai que moi je comprends pas on
comprendra alors service a été battu par
song quétier way sur france3 regarder
mais je suis chroniqueur médias
maintenant vous avez des audiences
partout c'est magnifique
emma que je préférais the vault je pense
être d'accord avec moi c'est lara fabian
la femme a même fait pleurer pour ses
chansons je connais par coeur et dans un
vrai ça me fait pleurer quand elle donne
son avis sur les prestations et samedi
le dirigeant de tf1 ils ont ajouté un
petit truc en plus pour ses monologues
histoire d'être sûr de bien vous faire
chialer
non moi je suis vraiment troublé par
votre voix
j'ai eu des frissons
monstrueux alors sur terre faut pour
appuyer les discours sont si de lara
fabian
ils ont ajouté une musique triste de
piano pour beaucoup plus d'émotions vous
allez voir vous avais la chair de poule
à qui vous traverse un an des pieds à la
tête et est que ce qui se passe en vous
ne s'explique plus de 10 euros jones
janis qu'on n'était pas censé voir mais
il était tellement à fond qu'ils ont
décidé de montrer l'antenne dans une
petite ville d'avoir
on touche à la fois une volonté de dire
quelque chose peut-être aussi j'ai
l'impression tu ne corrigera ces jeunes
seront de traduire une certaine colère
comme on l'a fait sortir l'om c'est que
ce pianiste au fil de l'émission et
s'est un peu enflammés et les monologues
émouvant de lara fabian c'est devenu
n'importe quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une candidate qui a fait beaucoup parler
d'elle samedi soir c'est une certaine
laure ouais alors l'or à la reprise je
m'appelle bagdad chanson préférée d'eric
zemmour et trois coaches ce sont autant
d allah chaque coach lutte pour
récupérer cette meuf dans ce sens en
équipe mais lara fabian elle décide de
mettre le paquet elle pour la séduire
vous allez voir c'est pas hyper efficace
[Musique]
alors elle assez lu amel ben pascal
obispo lara fabian
mais pour la convainc que lara fabian
décide de sortir des gros moyens j'ai
choisi je voudrais juste vous inviter à
chanter avec moi l'olympia sont alors
allés complètement choqué il paraît que
c'est son rêve alors négocié lui pose la
question
non qui saura t'on coulisses et ailleurs
d'ailleurs il aura le choix entre la
fabian amel bent et pascal obispo je
rappelle que lara fabian a quand même
décidé d'inviter leur a chanté avec elle
dans la mythique salle de l'olympia et
même son père il nous dit que le rêve
ultime de l'homme c'est de chanter avec
lara alors forcément pour la remercier
l'or a bien entendu choisir
[Applaudissements]
croit d'abord à l'olympia si tu veux je
viens moi mais se dit enfin nathan c'est
pareil les yeux tels la terre battue
permet je tue pas mes chaussettes voilà
pour ceux nombreux qui n'ont pas le
temps de regarder the voice samedi je
vous ai fait un petit résumé en 50
secondes c'est le 50 secondes insa et
notamment regarder un petit aperçu bien
sûr à regarder juste jolie on parlera de
sébastien folin dont 50 secondes
or pascal obispo et prend six cent mille
euros poppers os mais en vrai ils
préfèrent un gagné nancy clopé dit dans
questions pour un champion s'avoue un
peu trop dense ne voyez pas que du chant
ça rigole encore plus que dans la grosse
rigolade
[Rires]
[Musique]
et heureusement qu'on rigole un peu
parce que pour regarder the vault et
faut être en parfaite état psychologique
parce que c'était des prix mais que tu
habite au 6e étage
tu sautes direct jeudi maladie au fort
j'étais quand même avis que ça faisait
comme de l'arthrose dans tout le corps
et je suis drôle depuis dix ans dans une
association qui lutte contre la
drépanocytose dont trois dotés en fait
j'ai toujours eu cette peur du rejet de
la demande
et puis on a la chance d'avoir chaque
semaine nikos et toutes ces grandes
pensées philosophiques extraordinaire
qui font que se transforme en maître
aliagas
je souhaite
autour du pasteur
[Applaudissements]
ç'a pris du plaisir
oui alors il faut continuer
l'alcool c'est m
[Musique]
et on a découvert une candidate venue
depuis tahiti qui se promènent pignon
est forcément pieds nus sur un plateau
ça te fait des pieds encore plus
dégueulasse que ceux de jean michel
maire
il reste une dernière chose on se disait
très lent se voit ces jurys se bat pour
convaincre les candidats de rejoindre
leur équipe alors pour ça qu'ils sont
très forts mais là où ils sont encore
plus fort c'est quand il explique à un
mec qui a été viré doit rentrer chez lui
et en fait il est de la même chose que
quand ta meuf elle te quitte pour rompre
elle te dis que tu es génial mais je te
quitte quand même eh ben le jury de the
voice c'est pareil pari quand ils
peuvent te quitte
elle te dis que même si elle te dégage
tu as toutes les qualités du monde et
bat pascal obispo marc lavoine il
disparaît en dix ans c'est quand même
vraiment bien pour toutes les qualités
tu les as quand une meuf de kittel te
dit qu'elle ne veut plus de toi mais en
fait elle c'est plus pour quelle raison
et bat marc lavoine encore une fois
séparé écoutez je ne comprends pas trop
pourquoi je ne me suis pas retourné je
ne sais pas pourquoi mes camarades non
plus pourtant ce que vous avez fait très
bien mais la meilleure excuse du monde
c'est quand même celle amel bent est
l'os carrément utiliser le fameux tu es
trop bien pour moi et mylan je chante
super bien ça c'est une évidence
ok merci moi je me suis pas retourné
parce que justement un petit peu trop
bien chanter pour cette chanson du cenou
lui que ça veut dire que l'année
prochaine il faut absolument que cette
personne se serait pas au vol
tu es un très très bon joueur
[Applaudissements]